siguen los esfuerzos diplomáticos para
intentar desde escalar la crisis en
ucrania el presidente de francia
emmanuel macrón afirmó estar muy
preocupado y anunció una nueva reunión
con joe biden que enviará 3.000 soldados
al este de europa tenemos reportes de
ciertos
la justicia de nicaragua cercana al
presidente daniel ortega comenzó los
juicios contra más de 40 opositores
detenidos previo a las elecciones
presidenciales dos de ellos fueron
declarados culpables de supuesta
conspiración hablamos con la esposa de
uno de los presos políticos
nicaragüenses
en colombia cuatro mil doscientos
sesenta y ocho niñas entre 10 y 14 años
y 109 mil 823 adolescentes menores de 19
años fueron madres en 2020 según cifras
oficiales reveladas hoy embarazos que
por el rango de edad están tipificados
en el código penal como causa de
violencia sexual analizamos en esta
emisión
bienvenidos a esta emisión de noticias
de france 24 soy rodrigo sedano el
presidente de eeuu autorizó el
movimiento de 3.000 soldados hacia
europa del este en medio de las
tensiones con rusia por su despliegue de
tropas en la frontera con ucrania hoy el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
habló por teléfono con su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin ambos insistieron en el
diálogo como base para solucionar la
crisis de ucrania nuestro enviado
especial a kiev xavier colás tiene más
detalles de la conversación
por johnson advertido a vladimir putin
de que cometerá un error trágico de
cálculos e invade ucrania lo ha hecho en
una llamada telefónica que tenía
pendiente desde el lunes y que viene
precedida de serias advertencias por
quien se había quejado de que no se ha
satisfecho la principal demanda de rusia
de garantías de seguridad
el presidente ruso también le ha dicho a
johnson que quiere está involucrada en
el sabotaje crónico de los acuerdos de
minsk diseñados para alcanzar un punto
de la resolución político en ucrania
logrando mayor autonomía bombas el
camino ha dicho cómo va a responder una
vez más pero ha dicho que sigue
esperando una respuesta favorable de la
otan a unas preocupaciones que rusia
considera de sobra justificadas el
ministro de asuntos exteriores de rusia
serguéi lávrov también se ha dirigido en
las últimas horas a eeuu para pedir que
contesten de manera afirmativa a las
preocupaciones rusias rusas sobre su
propia seguridad
por su parte el presidente manuel macrón
también insistió en la apuesta por la
des escalada a través del diálogo como
solución a la crisis ya anunció una
nueva conversación con joe biden y no
descartó una nueva visita a quiet ni a
moscú
estoy evidentemente muy preocupado por
la situación sobre el terreno he tenido
muchos intercambios en los últimos días
con mis homólogos europeos con el
presidente putin en varias ocasiones con
el presidente de lenski y en las
próximas horas hablaré con el presidente
de byd en en cualquier caso estamos
tratando de encontrar un programa común
en nicaragua más de 40 opositores al
gobierno de daniel ortega detenidos
previo a las elecciones de noviembre en
las que el presidente fue reelegido sin
participación de la oposición ni de
observadores internacionales se
enfrentan a juicios por supuesta
traición dos de ellos fueron ya
declarados culpables este martes desde
miami berta vaya activista por los
derechos humanos en nicaragua y esposa
de félix madariaga es candidato
presidencial encarcelado habló para
france24 sobre la situación de los
presos políticos en el país dentro
actualmente en nicaragua existen 170
personas presas políticas de estas 170
alrededor de 120 que llevan ya casi 13
años de estar en prisión y hay un grupo
que fue secuestrado después de mayo del
año pasado estos son el liderazgo de
nicaragua hay alrededor de 42 personas
que se encuentran en las celdas
conocidas como el chipote y estas
personas este donde está mi esposo
también están sufriendo otros tipos de
torturas por ejemplo conocemos el caso
de rojas rey es uno de los defensores y
también abogado de félix que han sufrido
psicosis está perdiendo la memoria
personas que están incomunicadas
completamente y personas que están
perdiendo más de 60 libras es por el
proceso
en colombia durante el año 2020
4.268 menores de entre 10 y 14 años y
109 mil 823 adolescentes menores de 19
años se convirtieron en madres según las
cifras que reveló el reciente informe
del departamento
administrativo nacional de estadística
para hablar de estas cifras tenemos a
catalina martínez directora regional del
centro de derechos reproductivos y
vocera de causa justa
catalina que implican estas cifras de
menores de edad que han sido madres y
cómo afecta a la vida de estas mujeres
bueno estas cifras son realmente muy
preocupantes esto nos demuestra que no
se está protegiendo a las niñas de los
adolescentes en el país niñas entre 10 y
14 años que están dando a luz es
realmente muy triste por varias razones
primero porque esto pone realmente en
riesgo su salud y su vida las niñas y
los adolescentes de tan temprana edad
tienen cuatro veces más riesgo de sufrir
algún tipo digamos de secuela física
psicológica
y en su salud en general a causa del
embarazo y lo segundo además de esto es
que por supuesto son niñas que terminan
estando después en decepción escolar que
no vuelven al colegio que no pueden
formar sus proyectos de vida entonces
realmente son cifras aterradoras y
cifras que nos demuestran que colombia
le está fallando en políticas públicas
las vidas de adolescentes y
específicamente en políticas públicas
para acceder a servicios de salud sexual
y reproductiva
catalina el aborto todavía está
tipificado en colombia como ilegal por
el código penal como contribuye esto a
perpetuar los embarazos muchas veces
derivados de casos de violencia sexual
así es en colombia el delito aborto
existe pero el delito aborto tiene tres
causales sobre las cuales las mujeres y
las niñas podrían acceder al aborto una
de ellas es la causal violación sexual y
lo que estamos viendo es que esa causal
que es legal y bajo la cual acceder al
aborto en el país es un derecho
fundamental no está siendo respetada
porque ver que niñas de entre 10 y 14
años están dando a luz en el país quiere
decir que estas niñas no podrían acceder
al aborto en condiciones legales bajo
esta causal de violencia sexual porque
todo embarazo y una niña menor de 14
años debe presumirse que fue el
resultado de una violación sexual
entonces esto nos lleva a decir que las
causales no están siendo suficientes que
necesitamos que se elimine el delito del
código penal
muchas gracias catalina por este
completo reporte nos vamos ahora hasta
mexico que juega esta noche un partido
crucial contra panamá en las
eliminatorias al mundial de qatar de
fútbol 2022 en el imponente estadio
azteca uno de los escenarios deportivos
más del mundo allí habrá sólo unos 2.000
aficionados por una nueva sanción de la
fifa contra el país latinoamericano por
los continuos cánticos homófobos veamos
méxico a las afueras del estadio azteca
de ciudad de méxico el pasado fin de
semana los fanáticos que fueron a ver el
partido de clasificación de la selección
nacional contra costa rica fueron
recibidos con algunos novedosos
requisitos de entrada un cuestionario
especial un código qr personalizado y
una serie de advertencia a partir de
ahora quien sea sorprendido coreando
cánticos homófobos se enfrenta a una
prohibición de cinco años para entrar al
estadio ya estamos hartos de que nos
están multando de que nos estén
suspendiendo si pueden ingresar a los
partidos y sobre todo yo creo que ya es
momento de tener un buen comportamiento
de no discriminar y también cero
violencia durante las últimas dos
décadas corear jerga despectiva contra
los porteros del equipo contrario se ha
convertido en una costumbre indecorosa
en las gradas mexicanas
desde 2015 la federación mexicana de
fútbol ha sido multada unas 15 veces por
la fifa por reincidencia pero ahora se
está adoptando un enfoque de tolerancia
cero' una medida bien recibida por la
floreciente liga de fútbol el eje más de
ciudad de méxico mientras el país se
prepara para compartir las funciones de
anfitrión con eeuu y canadá para la copa
del mundo de 2026 entonces tenemos que
estar preparados como cultura porque en
el próximo año que este año que termina
el mundial del próximo año que inicia
nuestro proceso tenemos que abrirnos al
mundo no y decir venga esto es méxico y
en mexico se respeta no se apoya el
partido del domingo estaba destinado a
jugarse en un estadio vacío como castigo
por los cánticos homófobos antes de que
gméxico apelará con éxito la decisión de
la fifa el resultado final en sí mismo
un símbolo de igualdad fue un empate de
0 a 0
hasta aquí este repaso de toda la
información internacional les invitamos
a seguir conectados en france24 y
ampliar toda la información en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom
[Música]